everyone our next speaker is Hyundai
gabon from Yale University and is gonna
talk about approximation guarantees for
a greedy low ranked approximation okay
so thank you all for coming so this is
joint work with a few guys from UT
Austin Rajeev and Ethan are great grad
students there and then Alex DeMarcus is
a professor in the ECE department and so
I'm going to talk about is greedy low
rank matrix approximation problems and
we're gonna establish our goal would be
to establish new bounds for doing low
rank matrix approximation in a greedy
way and we're going to do that by
drawing connections with sub modular
optimization and sort of taking ideas
from that community in order to
establish new approximation guarantees
from the optimization perspective and
the statistical perspective all right so
our goal is to provide sort of a novel
analysis for greedy low rank matrix
approximation by establishing these
connections with some modular
optimization and so what we want to do
is we want to maximize some function
some L of theta subject to the non
convex constraint that theta has bounded
rank and our goal our method of doing
this will be to just greedily add rank
one components in every iteration so at
every iteration will have some theta K
we want to figure out what's the right
rank one component to add and then just
add to that
all right and so informally the result
that we show is the following as we take
K iterations so when we take K
iterations at every iteration we add a
rank one matrix which means our matrix
is at most
rank K what we're able to show is that
our loss or our objective that we want
to maximize is the greedily approximated
one the theta K has a multiplicative
lower bound approximation with respect
to the best rank or version so we let
fade a star be the best rank our matrix
that actually solves this problem and
we're able to show this multiplicative
this multiplicative guarantee so to be
clear we're allowing our approximation
to be of larger rank so when we look at
this exponential it's e to the minus CK
over R so C will be some constant that
only depends on the loss K is the number
of iterations that we take so it's the
rank of our solution and then we're
trying to compare to the best rank our
solution
so as one obvious example in low rank
matrix approximation we have our theta
star it can be decomposed in terms of
some factors and then what we might have
are noisy observations of the form fee
of theta IJ and so this is what you have
in an exponential family so for example
I might have theta star which are
underlying sort of desirability of a
product so I might think Emma's users
and are the products and I have some
underlying desire for that but I don't
actually observe a number a noisy above
the noisy corrupted observation of that
number instead I might just see like or
dislike another example is a
co-occurrence matrix of words I might
just see words across words and then
we'll know sort of how often one word
follows another word so I can see a
co-occurrence matrix and then that might
have a low rank because we might think
that we can embed words in some lower
dimensional space similarly for the
users in the ratings we might think that
we can embed users and movies in some
lower dimensional space and so what we
want to do is basically take these
observations and recover the underlying
matrix data star and so this is
connected way back to exponential family
PCA of Collins
at all and so basically what we want to
show our sort of theoretical guarantees
for doing this recovery so we're going
to do that by connecting the problem -
atomic approximations all right so what
does that mean we want to estimate from
some set CK where CK is the set of arc
of all our combinations from some atoms
so CK is the sum from I equals 1 to R of
C sub I a sub I given that a sub I come
from some atomic set and what we want to
do is we want to find theta hat that's
the Arg max over the set of theta so
obviously for rank R matrices we can
just take the atomic set to be rank one
matrices of operator are bounded by one
and so now this general framework has a
very very long history with all sorts of
different types of recovery guarantees
sometimes rediscovered sometimes applied
for different
different settings and so in our case
we're focusing explicitly just on the
rank one matrices that's our atomic of
our atomic set and then so we are able
to treat this problem now as a kind of
asset optimization where our set is
something that we select from the set of
atoms and then we optimize over those so
be more precise so to be precise suppose
we have some algorithm that can select a
new atom so for us that means it selects
a new rank one matrix and then let L be
the set of indices of those selected out
of those selected atoms so now for us in
this case we're going to think of the
atoms as both the some left singular
vectors and right singular vectors and
so you might have a column space in a
row space indexed by L so L selects the
column space vectors and it selects the
row space vectors and so we have u sub L
and V sub L and then with that we can
define a set function so we define the
set function f of L is equal to the max
over this matrix H which is L by L of L
of U sub L H V sub L minus L of 0 so now
once we've specified the row space in
the column space then it's just a much
easier problem if L were concave then
this is an easy problem to to optimize
over and so thinking of say a special
case like in sparsity in maximizing over
H would be like in sparse optimization
if I selected an appropriate sub set of
indices and I only up sit optimized on
those weights so for us so the
equivalent sort of problem in sparsity
would be something like maximizing over
some F of s where the cardinality of s
is upper bounded by K so for us we're
selecting some set that has a bounded
cardinality but it's coming from an
infinite size set so now this links us
to some modular functions so some
modular maximization is all about
maximizing functions over some
cardinality constraints or some set
constraint
and so a set function f that map's AP
subsets to R is some modular for all a
and B a subset of P so where P is 1 to P
if F of a plus F of B is lower bounded
by F of a union B plus F of a intersect
B so this set function is normalized if
f of the empty set is 0 and then it's
monotone if I take any B that's a
superset of a then F of B is greater
than or equal to F of a and so for us
that's like saying if I select more low
rank matrices then I'm able to optimize
my objective L the objective L better
and so one way to optimize over these
problems is to just pick an element that
maximizes so pick an element over the
set of remaining coordinates that
maximizes the objective and then just
add that to the set so we just greedily
keep adding an element from our from our
space and then just work with that and
then so we know this result by nemhauser
from 78 that says if we take the greedy
style algorithm then for a monotone some
modular functions the greedy guarantees
a 1 minus 1 over e approximation so that
is we get that lower multiplicative
bound of 1 minus 1 over e so the greedy
method a simple method can still do
pretty well when we compare to the to
the best-case search method
so now we can talk about something
called weeks of modularity so this form
of some modularity is a bit it's a bit
strong and for us our problem won't
necessarily satisfy some modularity and
indeed whenever we're talking about some
agility we're talking about a finite
class but for us again it's over an
infinite set of atoms so what does that
mean and so for the first step we use
this notion of weeks of modularity that
was introduced by Dawson Kemp a and now
they introduced this for analyzing
sparse linear regression problems so
these are just linear regression
problems where the weights have to be
sparse only a small subset of the
indices matter and so they introduced
the following the following concept so
suppose we take s and L to be disjoint
sets and we take F is a set function
then the sub modularity ratio of L with
respect to s is given by gamma L comma s
which is the sum over J and s of F of L
Union J minus F of L so now this is like
taking L and if I add each individual
element from J and then sum up how much
each individually contributes and then
we divide that by L Union s so now we
just take s all at once
put it all in and see how much better we
get and we take this ratio so the sub
modularity ratio of a set u with respect
to an integer K is then given by gamma
UK is the min over all disjoint L and s
where L is a subset of U and absolute
value of cardinality of s is upper
bounded by K
so use just an arbitrary set now right
so if you have this sub modularity ratio
this gamma then what one can show and
what Dawson can pay show is that you can
instead of getting that 1 minus 1 over e
approximation now you get a 1 minus 1
over e to the gamma approximation and so
what that says is you'd like gamma to at
least be strictly positive and indeed if
the function f were some modular then
gamma is at least greater than or equal
to uh there's one yeah so if semaj
allure is if and only if gamma is
greater than equal to 1 and so we can
see that from the previous definition
and if you're familiar with some modular
optimization that's kind of like the
incremental gains as you add to a larger
set the benefit isn't as isn't as large
now the issue with this is that it's
defined for finite sets and it's not
directly applicable to our settings so
for us if I have two atoms I can have
one atom a set of atoms in another set
of atoms that are completely disjoint
but for the most part are almost the
same I can just take an epsilon
perturbation of a rank one matrix and
they're basically in terms of my
approximation roughly equivalent so
instead what we do is we generalize this
notion of the sum modularity ratio to
atoms so for and specifically now this
is for low rank matrices so for us we
take s and L to be subsets of the atom
set so for us that's rank one matrices
and they're disjoint and now the
elements of s are orthogonal with
respect to the elements of L so now
we're saying s and L can't even be they
can't really be close the information
that s is giving on top of L is sort of
orthogonal to it and now we take the
cardinality of L to be K the cardinality
of s to be R and then F is some set
function then we define this sum
modularity ratio now in exactly the same
way just gamma of L comma R is the sum
over a and
of F of L Union a - F of L divided by F
of L Union s minus F of L and then again
we can define the semaj Alera t ratio of
the set of another set of atoms U with
respect to some K just by the min over
all of these sets and so now this
basically just generalizes the notion of
weeks of modularity yeah so what you're
saying is that s is it an L or
respectively including into our own
subspaces so that I'll try to be so L is
a set of atoms so just some arbitrary
set of rank one matrices and then s is
another set of rank one matrices but
we're we're assuming that the elements
in s the row spaces of each atom is
orthogonal to the row spaces of the
atoms in L and the column spaces of the
atoms in s are orthogonal to the column
spaces of the atoms in now and so then
this is the notion of weeks of
modularity that we want satisfied for
low rank matrices and sort of
generalizing just kind of like infinite
sets
okay so now with that we take another
element so we have this weeks of
modularity notion and now we take an
idea from statistics and from optima and
from constrained optimization the notion
of restricted strong concavity and
restricted smoothness and so all that
means is that if we have our matrix
variate function l so remember we're may
be thinking of L as our log likelihood
if we have our matrix variate function L
then it's restricted strongly concave
with parameter M Omega and restricted
smooth with parameter M Omega if for all
x and y in some appropriate set Omega
then the first order Taylor
approximation of L is lower bounded by a
quadratic and upper bounded by a
quadratic so it's just smooth and
strongly concave like we're used to but
now we're doing it over restricted sets
all right so L when we say it's M sub I
strongly concave we mean that it's M sub
I strongly concave over rank I matrices
so coming back here the set Omega for
little em'ly is rank I matrices so X is
an arbitrary rank I'm eight or rank yeah
I matrix and Y is an arbitrary rank I
matrix for the smoothness part we need
that L is M to one smooth over the
following set Omega where the rank of X
minus y is just one so whereas in the
strong concavity part we need x and y to
be arbitrary rank i matrices for the
smoothness part all we need is y and x
there difference to be ranked from 1 and
this is going to this has to do with in
the algorithm we're always updating by a
rank one matrix and so the next iterate
is only different by rank one so in
pictures that basically means over our
constraint set we have our blue function
which is our actual desired L that we're
trying to maximize over that
log-likelihood and then we just have
some upper and lower bound control on
those on the function alright so this is
then our main result the restricted
strong convexity concavity and
restricted smoothness of the function l
actually implies weeks of modularity so
recall that we define our set function
in this way F of L so L is the set of
atoms that we've selected is equal to
the max over this H of L of U sub L H V
sub L minus L of 0 and so now we want to
lower bound the semaj Alera T ratio and
we get the following so if L is a set of
K rank 1 atoms and up to our additional
atoms are all orthogonal to atoms in L
and they are greedily added then gamma L
R that's some modularity ratio for low
rank matrices is lower bounded just by
the strong concavity over the strong
smoothness
M sub R plus K divided by M sub one and
so with this we can basically
immediately prove guarantees on a greedy
method for solving the rank R
approximation problem so this sort of
thing extends the previous result by
elenberg at all in US that gives you
weeks of modularity for general sparse
optimization but it should be important
to note that in this case and in that
case we're not implying actual sub
modularity it's just this weeks of
modularity so we can get now get greedy
approximation bounds so we have two
greedy algorithms that one can consider
one is orthogonal matching pursuit for
matrices and then so that's we can think
of approximate greedy the Gecko
algorithm or ad mira or you can just do
the full-on greedy method which is a
forward step wise selection so if we're
taking Ellison log likelihood of a
statistical model then this is
guaranteeing us some type of log
likelihood for the parameter that we
that we achieve now there is an issue
with the greedy method so we could just
directly plug in the gamma and will
obtain convergence guarantees but now
the problem is for low rank matrices if
you want to do the full on greedy
approach for anything but quadratic
functions its intractable in the sparse
case where you have a finite set you
could at least search and out so you're
searching over all P things in our case
you have an infinite number of things
that you're going to have to search over
and the only place where it's easy to do
and we know how to prove things on is
then in the quadratic case because in
that case you can use the power method
so what's nice then isn't you can rather
than doing the forward stage wise greedy
you just do the orthogonal matching
pursuit or gecko which we'll describe
now so the OMP selection so it's
described in a lot of nice detail and
shall I the Schwarz and others
we'll choose the atom that satisfies the
following so we're at our optimization L
so we've selected the L atoms you take
the gradient of respect with respect to
that and then we want to find the rank
one matrix that satisfies this lower
bound so it's greater than or equal to
tau for some towel strictly greater than
one less strictly greater than zero less
than one of the max over U and V of this
and now so if we ignore the towel well
if we take tau to say be 1/2 then what
this basically means is we can
effectively just run the power method up
to approximation half to get this rank
one this rank one solution that
maximizes it and what's interesting is
that with this scheme if s is the
solution that the greedy method pulls so
after K iterations then we can show that
F of s is lower bounded by one minus e
to the minus tau squared this week's a
modularity ratio times K over R and then
times F of s star so if we take for a
second tau equal to one say you can do
the power method perfectly and then you
just run it this basically exactly kind
of recovers the solution from Dawson
campaign where they had the weeks of
modularity except now you have an
additional a Tau squared term because of
this this approximation
so what we'll next talk about are sort
of other results in this realm of atomic
optimization which I alluded to before
because this this problem of atomic
optimization is quite quite old and
there's a lot of different results in it
and a lot of those results come in a few
different flavors so in order to define
the results first I'll define the atomic
norm this is also the total variation
norm with respect to a dictionary which
is what is called in Baron at all but I
think a lot of people are familiar with
atomic norms and so I'll just stick to
that and so when atomic norm V is just
equal to the int the sum of absolute
value of C sub I where V is a linear
combination of elements in the atomic
set so if the atomic set were coordinate
vectors this would be the l1 norm for us
the low rank matrices this is the
nuclear norm or the sum of the singular
values and then so a lot of the bounds
that exist in the literature are of the
form L of theta hat K is greater than
greater than or equal to L of theta star
minus some Epsilon so we have a
multiplicative bound most the results in
the literature prove proven additive an
additive them
and then so we can kind of compress a
lot of the different results and you get
kind of three different types of bounds
with respect to this epsilon so one
other type of balance is just the atomic
norm squared of the optimal solution
divided by K and the super number K is
like the number of iterations that
you've taken and so this you can do kind
of in the general case using kind of
ideas from gradient descent and Frank
wolf optimization so another method is
if the function is strongly concave then
in that case people have shown
exponential decrease of the form alpha
to the K L of theta star but in this
case alpha is usually of the form e to
the minus 1 over D 1 we're say where the
matrix is say D 1 by D 1 and then
another form that also exists in the
literature if it satisfies restricted
strong convex concavity so this is
strongly concave over the entire space
this is restricted strongly concave
another result is L of 0 R over K but
what ends up happening is oftentimes
we'd like epsilon to be of the order R
times D 1 plus D 2 over n the reason is
is this is frequently the statistical
guarantee where in this case R is the
rank we want our matrix is D 1 by D 2
and then n represents the number of
observations so say for instance in a
matrix completion problem if you observe
n items from the matrix
so for instance the different users tell
you if they like or dislike a movie and
you only have n of those well a lot of
results in this from the statistics and
machine learning community show that the
error behavior of estimating the theta
star is of the form R times D 1 plus D 2
over N and these are these are minimax
so these are basically optimal so you'd
like to have this type of bound but then
in that case in order to have our error
bound epsilon to reach this small we
frequently have to take K the number of
iterations so remember R is the target
rank K is the number of iterations then
K has to end up growing linearly in
energy
and then that's a problem because for a
lot of problems the rank R might be much
much smaller than d1 or the number of
observations so for our bound what we
end up getting is epsilon behaves of the
order e to the minus gamma K K over R so
what that means is for us we basically
need to take K to be like R times log n
so we still need to take our rank to be
larger but by a much smaller amount then
the existing work in order to achieve
sort of the desired statistical
statistical guarantees so and we can see
we can see that we can unwrap our result
so if we take any rank R matrix so this
is some arbitrary rank R matrix this
isn't like the best one this isn't one
that comes from a statistical model this
is just any rank R matrix and if we
denote that to be theta star then we can
show the following optimization bound
the greedy algorithm achieves the
following error rate you choose Stata
hat sub K minus theta star in Frobenius
norm squared is upper bounded by e to
the minus gamma R over K times L of 0 so
this is like our approximation error
then plus R plus K the operator norm of
the gradient divided by gamma star get
gamma squared so for a second if we
ignore this this is the sort of the
familiar statistical error bound that we
would achieve typically you have your
the operator norm of the gradient if
your are coming from some statistical
model is going to behave like the square
root of the dimension of the matrix and
then so you end up with the statistical
bound and then Plus this convergence
this optimization convergence and so
that's exactly where this bound comes
from we just said that to be this
epsilon
so we can also see some experiments to
see well how well does this type of idea
do in practice the scoop de and Collins
and their exponential PCA paper have a
lot of nice experiments but we also ran
some of our own so in this case we just
look at the stochastic block model but
in a very simple form where the
probability of inside connections is P
and outside connections is 1 minus P and
then all we do is we estimate the matrix
after observing the binary variables and
with this type of log likelihood so this
is just the log likelihood that you
would get if you're going to assume that
the observations are coming from some
exponential family and so when we look
at that one thing that we thought was
interesting and so we only are comparing
against spectral methods one is a
normalized method one is just the silly
unnormalized method and then one is the
greedy method and then what we have here
is just a generalization error so the
probability of correctly putting people
into the right cluster into the right
group and here we have five groups and
so what we see is we have different sort
of ranks 3 5 10 and in the greedy case
one thing that we thought was
interesting is that it seems more robust
to picking the right the right rank we
see similar type of results for
reconstruction error so instead of
looking at probability of correct
clustering or assignment we look at
reconstructing the parameter matrix and
again we see something similar so at the
end what we have is we've interpreted
this low-rank approximation problem as a
set optimization over an infinite set of
atoms and showed a new analysis for the
greedy optimization and I heard people
talk about word embeddings before we
have some word embedding experiments in
our in our paper as well okay thank you
question 10 sue how about being a little
a little more complicated than having
the way steps lights up sometimes called
the way steps where you not only take
greedy steps with you throw away things
yeah so that the away steps I guess also
in the statistical side that come like a
forward backward optimization so we're
actually looking at that right now and
at least in the sparse optimization
setting the forward backward method
works well in terms of not needing to go
above the rank you would just need a BSA
at two times the desired rank the
problem is at least the forward backward
algorithm or the away steps that we see
in in the spar setting computationally
they start getting it starts getting way
worse to to start deleting things but
yeah we're actually working on it right
right now thanks good question your
depends on so in the in the bounds that
I showed the the recovery bounds in
order to even have restricted strong
convexity we kind of need the fade at
the Frobenius norm of the theta star to
be bounded in some in some unit ball
basically and so that assuming that our
parameters are in some bound it and some
bounded ball removes at least the d
dimensionality but then we still have
root end dimensionality but then that
gets killed because of the exponential
[Applause]